hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday July 22nd 2019 what's going
on how are you doing
podcast is very late today I'd like to
apologize to all the people out there
affected especially the ladies I know
being a woman it's just so much harder
to download a podcast than it is for a
man and it's something that people with
penises just cannot understand and and
then furthermore when you compiled it
with the fact that you call it the
Monday morning podcast and you make a
promise to to put the podcast on Monday
morning and it doesn't happen I just
feel like it brings up a lot of daddy
issues I would say dad can I have
cornflakes in a wine and he'd be like
yeah and in the morning I'd have Froot
Loops sorry I'm sorry I should have
called it the Monday evening podcast
occasionally but mostly it's the Monday
morning podcast Oh Billy freckles Oh
Billy thespian Billy Shakespeare Emma
said shake square can't say that anymore
shakes homosexual nobody said I what the
[ __ ] he's supposed to say I don't know
what you're supposed to say well maybe
if you cared more but now go [ __ ]
yourself I live in my own [ __ ] world
all right
I hold the door for people I make sure I
got my MetroCard out you know if I'm
looking at my [ __ ] phone when I walk
down the streets of New York I get up
against a building
okay that's what I do visible [ __ ] that
you can see okay and you can put it all
in the consideration column people
walking around with your [ __ ] words
and you're still acting like a [ __ ]
well good for you with all your [ __ ]
happy words you know no one likes you oh
yeah I went there
nobody likes you who bill who are you
talking about people people who [ __ ]
bug me I'm gonna [ __ ] that I mean I am
overtime I had to go on set today and
say things that other people wrote and
it's just so exhausting try being an
actress
anyway um they had a 5:00 a.m. call when
I got a [ __ ] paper route again is
that what it is you got one of them
paper routes when I was a kid when I was
a lad
you know coming up in the 70s bump ample
Mappin open oh hey freckles I had a
paper route kids had paper routes they
got up in the morning got on bicycles
and they rode around the neighborhood
dressed his paper boys daring somebody
to kidnap them did it every [ __ ]
morning pretty much except for one trip
we took one family trip between third
grade and ninth grade I've told you
these stories before started in third
grade
and it was cute although the little
ginger [ __ ] guy with the big bag
right by the time I was in ninth grade I
like Clinton wasn't cute anymore it's
just like ooh this kids not getting laid
anytime soon
yeah got a [ __ ] little kid job and
you're riding a bicycle I'll tell you I
haven't been high school in a while I'll
tell you right now as far as I remember
then Chili's was not into that vibe you
want to ride on my bike handles my
handlebars bike handles handlebars yep I
saved some money most of money I blew on
football cards and stupid [ __ ] candy
that doesn't even exist anymore remember
big buddy it was it just [ __ ] gum it
was like I swear to god it was like
12 inches long and it was just all one
stick of it Jayant think it just said
big buddy and you peeled it down yeah
you [ __ ] just bit it off like beef
jerky and you just kept going then of
course to make your friends laugh you'd
be like how much of the big buddy can
you get in your [ __ ] mouth this is
what we did before the internet this is
what you did when you lived in a house
and the UHF antenna didn't work so there
was no cartoons there was just the adult
channels during the day they just had
the [ __ ] news and Mike Douglas then I
would watch the occasional comedian but
you know all my friends were watching
Tom and Jerry and Mighty Mouse and woody
wood you know the mighty heroes remember
the mighty heroes what was that a [ __ ]
did that song go something like tornado
man strong man diaper man and then there
was uh an coke I couldn't stand that
[ __ ] [ __ ] could not stand him he
was [ __ ] useless he could barely get
off the ground
you know I think I liked or I liked
strong man that was the guy I liked
anyway going down the road here Jonny
Quest that type of [ __ ] all my friends
were watching that crap and where was I
sitting in a home all by myself in a
busy busy street watching days of our
lives
mom gets it true you can come back if
you fall off a cliff asking her those
kinds of questions you know soap opera
storylines
anyways I anyways I'm gonna continue so
that's how I said I don't give a [ __ ] I
know it's anyway I don't give a [ __ ]
anyways I got back there's nobody in my
apartment my beautiful wife my lovely
daughter were out with some family
members they're out there getting pizza
and everything and old freckles is on
the movie diet so I'm sitting here all
by myself eating a Mediterranean salad
with some chicken right not something I
want to do something I gotta do
alright I'm doing it for the craft okay
Tom Cruise he can learn how to fly
helicopters all day long but is he going
to sit there with the Mediterranean
salad all by himself is he gonna let all
his people go home and just sit there in
the silence just hearing that lettuce
echoing in your head as you chew in it
you know
I wonder I wonder if he's got it in him
um so I'm sitting there and what sounds
like from up the street goes New York's
always no noisy I thought it was like a
truck it sounded like this truck and
then a couple like the [ __ ] cops are
something on my card something's going
down and then it sounded like cheering I
was like what the [ __ ] is this and then
all of a sudden it just I just started
hearing this robber out bat that baby
died I'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
and it got louder right now yeah baby
coming down Steve was a [ __ ] parade
in in the middle of the rain I don't
know if it was a protest I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is so I [ __ ] open
the window and I'm looking out the
street they're like sorry if I hurt your
ears they should have tapped on the
chest sorry about that it was a [ __ ]
parade in the middle of the rain so a
couple of Puerto Rican flags I believe
so I know it's not Puerto Rican parade I
don't think so I don't know what all I
know is it's hard to get a [ __ ]
permit to have a [ __ ] legal parade so
but I don't know last night oh wait is
the Puerto Rican Day Parade coming up
cuz last night I saw like this whole
[ __ ] group of people on motorcycles
all different sizes the real ones and
then the little ones just tearing
through the [ __ ] town and then you
know you know that three-wheeled car
that you're not even enclosed I don't
know how its Street [ __ ] legal like
for those went by it was [ __ ] insane
and awesome all at the same time let's
look at maybe this is the pre Puerto
Rican Day Parade
when is that Sunday June 14th I missed
it I don't know Tom's going on I have no
idea maybe the Yankees signed somebody
alright maybe they're still not giving
relief to those poor people down there
and Puerto Rico I don't know maybe they
were just happy that was raining out the
[ __ ] heat wave was over but it was uh
pretty cool I miss New York Oprah in the
window and a parade just goes by it's
great I don't to be in the parade
I don't be trying to cross the street in
the parade like what happened with the
gay pride parade but the gay pride
parade goes by and I'm upstairs in an
air-conditioned unit
III am you know I'm up there [ __ ]
having a good time with everybody else
you know a little damsel who's that
chick who [ __ ] at Throwdown Rapunzel
now now Rapunzel yeah rapunzel rapunzel
let down your hair
I got a confuse of Rumplestiltskin
[ __ ] evil [ __ ] did he make that chick
[ __ ] she had her so she had golden
hair yeah I don't make it hoodies or
something like that dude is there
anything better than [ __ ] Rapunzel's
hair made into a hoodie with the gold
pair of Jordan air ones over over I'll
tell you right now you guys got to reach
out to Paul virzi Paul virzi podcast I
got him shook my sneaker game has
elevated you know good friend of mine
bought me a pair Jordan one's [ __ ]
virzi it's just like where he's been
texting me he just he doesn't even see
them on me cuz he just saw a picture of
him he goes through those Jordans are
sick he'll just in the middle of the
week those Jordan ones you got a sick
like I've never seen anybody him in
Yanis Papas today I've never seen two
people in two sneakers the way they are
they are like they're so into it you're
almost almost you know somebody so into
something you can't even make fun of him
you get like nervous like it's just like
making fun of somebody's religion
because this is what this is feeling
like but I've got him twice on this trip
twice with the sneakers and he's I don't
know
far is he actually opened for me it was
pretty cool we did this theater and in
Gould New Jersey it's it's the first
theater I ever did with Paul like 10
years earlier I remember driving up
there go man have been England wouldn't
a while and I started thinking like wait
is this the [ __ ] and Boise was open
it goes it's a [ __ ] place I've did
with Boise the second I walked in and I
saw the stage I was like oh [ __ ] this is
it so Paul comes in and I'm like Paul
he's like what's up I go dude look at
that stage because yeah man looks hit it
was just like you know what this this is
the first place you opened for me
remember right and he's just like nah
man he goes he goes is it
he goes you're into that nostalgic stuff
nostalgia it's like no dude it's it's
just having a memory nostalgic Jesus
Christ I'm not [ __ ] antiquing here
anyways he went out and [ __ ] ripped
it up he ripped it up Paul virzi ripped
it up while wearing but I've never seen
he was wearing a pair of Pumas brand new
of course looking sharp but I am in the
10 years this is me getting nostalgic
again evidently and the 10 years that
I've known that guy I have never seen
him in a pair of Pumas it's always been
Nike then he's thrown in a couple of
random random things but they're always
classic sneakers from a different era
like maybe like I don't know Glenn
Howard ones or [ __ ] I don't know who
that the hell of that is I'm trying to
think of a [ __ ] old time
Remiel Robinson twos or something like
that he'll break those out right but
I've never seen it but they were the old
school ones so I had ever said I had to
find out you know because a lot of
people don't know this Paul is a very
humble guy he keeps it on the down-low
he actually has one of the few non
athlete sneaker deals that Nike has ever
signed
it's like jay-z I mean oh if it's true
if those guys wear that [ __ ] then he
have the SD the shark the S dots the
Sean Carter's remember back in the day
Charlie Murphy rest his soul when those
things came out he got them all all the
colors that was the first time I was
introduced to people like you know and I
grew up you got a pair of sneakers at
the beginning of the year and then that
was it you actually were self-conscious
at how clean they were and after about a
month you felt a little bit better with
them right you'd show up with the new
[ __ ] sneakers alright then the one
broke kid would walk around accidentally
step on it you know he could beat the
[ __ ] out of you so you're like hey I
hope that was an accident
and then you just warm for the whole
[ __ ] year and that was it your mother
would buy him a half a size or a size
too big and that was it maybe that's
what it was maybe all these maybe all of
those kids they just wanted you know you
know they're in therapy not just don't
understand why my mom couldn't buy me
another pair for Thanksgiving or you
know how about Christmas and then they
do someday when I get old I'll go have
all the sneakers I ever wanted and every
day is going to look like the first day
of school I'm just [ __ ] with your
sneaker heads I respect it but then
there's another part that's just so
[ __ ] funny watching grown men in
their 40s still dressing like they're
waiting for a school bus I don't know
it's just something I don't know it's
it's the dress-down generation gone
[ __ ] nuts like it take dressed out
casual Friday began I remember in the
late 80s and I was working in a
warehouse at the time and they just
introduced casual Fridays and somebody
asked I remember they said what's candy
in the carpeted area where everybody
dressed like a [ __ ] little bud Fox
you know and they got themselves a
cubicle I've got a little ready got a
position that was the big thing they got
a position right in the carpeted area
people will somebody asked out there
remember they said what is casual Friday
and I was walking by said oh that's when
you guys dressed like us you know cuz
we're just always jeans and t-shirts
then they laughed and I felt good cuz I
got a laugh all right my hair was the
color of a fire engine and I needed I
needed to be reinforced I didn't have
the self-esteem to sit and talked to
myself on a microphone by myself for a
[ __ ] hour anyways and then my boss
ended up having a meeting about it he
was like uh you know last week Friday I
blew it was we had our first casual
Friday and somebody from the
somethin'-somethin department asked what
it was
what's casual Friday
bill burr said that's when you dress
like us they've got a little chuckle and
I was like how good I got another laugh
but I could feel the [ __ ] impending
doom coming and he's like I think we
should have a little more respect
still the 80s we're still tucking in our
t-shirts into our jeans it's not enough
for you coughing them at the top of our
[ __ ] ghost white Reebok aerobic high
tops that's not enough for you just
because you walk around and you got a
[ __ ] tie on and all of a sudden you
know you got a door and you're closing
it sitting in there with your air
conditioning you gonna [ __ ] tell us
how to drive try to say we should have
more self-esteem I was just saying like
that what fight is everybody kind of got
[ __ ] balled out because it make I'm
bringing that back by the way balled out
about Mike
fifth grade he got [ __ ] balled up
dude he got [ __ ] bagged he was
skipped in school he got [ __ ] bagged
yeah the principal was balling him out
and I would sounds oddly sexual sexual
but that's what it was he got balled out
I always took that to mean they take
your balls out and they just [ __ ] you
kick you in the [ __ ] seeds that's how
I always looked at him anyway I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
here
oh the carpeted area and then those
people they'd get in the carpeted they
get a position and all of a sudden they
did have a little skinny tie you know
leather they were crushing ass on the
[ __ ] weekend that have the Levitt tie
letting people know you know that it was
going down you [ __ ] he didn't have
any sideburns you just had it straight
across right above you [ __ ] here and
he had your leather tie maroon with the
black thin stripes and your black
leather tie tucked into your gray
Dockers your little [ __ ] belt that
came with the [ __ ] pants you little
[ __ ] dance slippers one of those
little skinny those [ __ ] shoes that
people had back then not that not the
[ __ ] office shoes you know like I'm
gonna wear but I'm gonna show people
that I'm cool and on the weekend I got a
little game with the ladies and they
they wear those days I swear to god they
look like they look
like dancing slippers that had like
shoestrings on came in white black you
know gray and all this [ __ ] and they'd
be walking around they get that [ __ ]
cubicle what's the first thing they did
making extra money they start saving
away huh continent let another [ __ ]
link off the chain I know what they do
they'd go out and they'd buy a new
[ __ ] car coming in like they were a
badass and the people above them was
psyched my brother told me that told me
it was a dumbest [ __ ] thing you could
ever do you stopped making more money
and then you spend more money I think
you think he was watching all these
[ __ ] people bill they go out there
and they buy the [ __ ] car and there's
stupid little skinny ties right and they
just they literally they just chained
themselves to their [ __ ] desk you
know he was giving me basically I was
just talking to straight about this
today they're he's basically giving
giving me the the Bronx tailed now you
can't leave speech like four or five
years before it ever came out you know
remember those [ __ ] cars one guy got
a good car though he's kind of a boss's
son though he got the Jeep renegade or
something like that remember was a big
deal because it had square headlights
front headlights and all Jeep purists
were flipping out because never in the
history of Jeep or Willy's did it ever
have square headlights and they were
saying it wasn't as good as the cj7 and
all that but I got to tell you that dude
took us out [ __ ] four wheeling in
that thing and uh wait the [ __ ] is this
thing hey bill we're running a show I
love to have you well Jesus Christ what
am I [ __ ] eighteen [ __ ] wiped out
um anyway he took us out for Whelan and
that thing and I could not and I
couldn't [ __ ] believe what it was
going through every time I thought it
would bottom out he'd you know and he
was beating this [ __ ] out of it like
only a boss's son drives a new car just
knowing enough there's another one there
you know it's like whenever you watch
American greed
and those [ __ ] [ __ ] they because
they're feeling guilty about the money
they're stealing they're being all
generous with everybody else and he's
they break in open bottles that are like
bottles of wine that are like [ __ ]
ten thousand dollars each and they're
like chugging them because it's never
gonna end right they just [ __ ] you
know it's the 80s was the time of excess
I missed out because I was a [ __ ]
teenager you know by the time I came of
age everybody knew that cocaine was the
big life was a big lie and they had all
those [ __ ] commercials you know with
the bacon and the eggs and people coming
on there with their [ __ ] nose all
blown out sitting there going like I had
a wife and I had children I had a
beautiful I also pull then I discovered
cocaine you know it started off as I
just it was a good time yeah baby feel
good I was easy to talk to I like I
liked who I was just talking I uh you
know once it'll help we came what's it
await you and you're like that I had
already tried so sure enough to work out
that you know it became stuff that I but
still taught the back of a toilet bowl
every other 20 minutes people kept
asking me what I was doing like you know
like dollar had allergies and I was just
really excited about it but eventually
never and I was on cocaine and I own
wife left me she started [ __ ] my
sober spot super that's a different
story and that's that's what I always
just saw everybody knew that [ __ ]
cocaine was like a bad [ __ ] deal you
know that which blows my mind I think
that everybody just knew that it was bad
so it like it kind of went away at least
wherever the [ __ ] I was at and then
somewhere like 10 11 years ago it just
came back with a vengeance and I just
remember thinking like people are doing
this again
what the [ __ ] look I get heroin because
the fentanyl and all of that [ __ ] was
never around so that just led people to
that that was like a new way in cocaine
he's just cocaine right I mean you know
what the [ __ ] it is you know what it's
gonna do to you
and people started doing I just was like
really says the guy who smokes too many
cigars alright I'm gonna get off my
[ __ ] stump here do you know you
people should live your lives you should
live your lives the way I pretend to
live my life that's the way you should
live in okay this episode is all about
me pretending like I've solved all my
problems did I talk to you guys about
addiction mmm-hmm my new uh this is my
new way of looking at addiction I think
I might have talked about this I don't
give a [ __ ]
I find it fast and I'm really starting
to think that addiction it like the
amount of [ __ ] you're [ __ ] addicted to
but like no one gives a [ __ ] like your
phone and food sugar salt and all of
that I think I already talked about this
so I really just came to this
realization that if I'm doing something
then in my heart of hearts I don't want
to be doing then I'm on some level I'm
addicted to it how many times late at
night you like walking home especially
back when I was boozing don't do it
don't do it don't do it let me get two
slices pepperoni mushroom what is that a
garlic knot why don't you [ __ ] throw
a couple of those on top and then just
coming over yeah just [ __ ] sucking it
down you know pine ice cream I'm only
gonna have the first third of it you
[ __ ] just showered it down and the
next morning you wake up looking like
the [ __ ] Michelin Man right like oh
why did I do that I don't want to do
that I want to be in shape I want to
turn heads when I walk down the street
who is that bald 51 year old pigment
Lisp person right but yet you still do
it
why do you dawn on some lie don't know
what it is you just [ __ ] game people
always just I know it's so hard but just
eating well is so hard
dude it's like [ __ ] impossible you
know I mean what am I gonna lose like
the pizzas good you know
those same [ __ ] people as they're
reading it will say to somebody in shape
be like dude I mean I just I mean you
could eat whatever the [ __ ] you want you
know I mean it just [ __ ] piles on
yeah well when you [ __ ] eat a whole
large cheats pizza yourself there fatso
so I guess doing something you don't
want to do but you know it's because
it's it's good for you is I guess being
disciplined like tonight I came on I was
just like yeah [ __ ] I could just feel
it I could feel it coming up you know
the food demon we just coming up burnt
one or two go on - pretty cool and like
I don't want to get I mean I'd like to
get a pizza and then fortunate is this
place to make salad so before I could
even give in to that I just went in I
was like measure a salad chicken Oh
close salad dressing do you want I'd
have enough [ __ ] you put on it dude
can't you see the sadness in my face you
really gonna make me order even more
just [ __ ] throw it on there now some
douche right now with excitement in his
or her fingertips it's gonna send me an
email and be like bill actually in a
calorie sense was probably better if you
ordered the pizza because a lot of salad
dressing actually have more calories
admit shut the [ __ ] up I don't give a
[ __ ] if it does okay I'm still eating
lettuce and [ __ ] fava beans whatever
the [ __ ] they they never know what that
they would the salad is such a [ __ ]
mystery to me like I don't even know
where to begin I kind of even [ __ ]
make one you know then you got to get
one of those [ __ ] knives you know
he's got two handles you just [ __ ]
you could go back and forth like [ __ ]
two people saw him down a tree in the
[ __ ] early 1900s I you know I've
eaten so many of those [ __ ] things on
this shoot and I really have no idea
what's in it we once in a while you spot
something that chickpea
um anyways Jesus Christ is that what you
got to do to stay in shape just [ __ ]
walking down the street in a head of
iceberg lettuce I would like to do that
one night right outside of an ice-cream
truck just sitting there eating a head
of lettuce and just shaking my head
slowly looking at all the people as they
order you know have like really dark
sunglasses on so you can't tell who I'm
looking at just shaking my head si order
yeah let me get a soft-serve double
bubbling oh Jesus excuse me buddy is
there a problem
god no I'm just just hanging out just
hanging out do you really need to I
heard that
how would you do that though
what could you secretly want an ice
cream yes exactly why I would do it you
know I'd like to have my own parade of
people [ __ ] eatin heads of lettuce
coming right down the street that people
eat nice cream wrap back
Redbeard well [ __ ] you you fat [ __ ]
right one of the most hateful parades
since the Nazis you know you're they go
back to the [ __ ] Nazis right just
body shaming I want to know I think we
all want to know who gave the permit for
that parade stop speaking for everybody
else they're right there double chin
okay you got more [ __ ] liquid between
your Chin's and the [ __ ] rainforest
[Music]
why bill why be mean like that I don't
know so hate a salad I'm in a bad move
give me a [ __ ] break
all right let's talk about let's talk
about sex baby let's talk about you and
me who is that let's talk about that
maybe let's talk about sex ladies that
was salt and pepper
salt and pepper she spelled it the right
way the way the people of Boston say it
salt and pepper dude you gotta go see
him I know they're not the right color
just don't tell your parents I think
we'll be fine
and that was 1988 all right let's see
here new dates oh I got some new dates
Robert rep Redrup I'm gonna be in
Asheville North Carolina I wish I knew
what they were saying if I could just
somehow slip into that parade and just
[ __ ] march down the street with them
and they Billy the [ __ ] is his [ __ ]
albino Puerto Rican Asheville North
Carolina
October 11th I'm gonna be at the Tomas
Thomas Wolfe auditorium presale is
Wednesday July 24th at 10:00 a.m. until
Thursday July 25th at 10:00 p.m. on sale
Friday July 26th at 10:00 a.m. I don't
know if this some sort of special code I
will ask me agent and I'll [ __ ] tweet
it out I'll do it right now so I don't
forget is there a special code for the
presale of the [ __ ] am i north carolina
show question mark it's hilarious it
literally wrote that out is there a
special for the presale of the [ __ ] am i
North Carolina show oh you know it's the
little things in life that just make you
laugh you know all right let's see here
what do we got here how far into my 30
minutes geez just like that I'll tell
you something about sunstroke just makes
a [ __ ] podcast go by real quick all
right let's uh let's do some reeds here
oh look who's back wait is this the
first [ __ ] Oh
good boys Oh them this is an advertising
read oh this is about a [ __ ] movie
oh this is exciting cuz this is I
believe this is uh Seth Rogen I love his
movies
alright good boys what if the guys who
made some of the most outrageous r-rated
comedies like Superbad and sausage party
decided to make an r-rated comedy
starring twelve-year-old boys jaysus
post me to their going hard well they
did it and it's the hilarious new movie
called good boys it follows three
innocent sixth graders as they skip
school one day to do whatever it takes
to learn how to kiss before their first
middle school party see I mean right
there that's how you sell a movie that's
how you pitch a movie good boys Walt
Devils waters at about it follow it's a
movie that follows three innocent sixth
graders and say skip school one day to
do whatever it takes to learn how to
kiss before their first middle school
party I'm buying it that's it this man
knows how to do business out there the
thing is they get themselves into a ton
of inappropriate and are rated
situations along the way early audiences
and critics have been raving about good
boys saying that you'll laugh for ninety
minutes straight they're calling it
delightfully inappropriate ah the
pendulum swinging back I'm feeling a
breeze after they wave wild raunchy I'm
seeing this the first night and
undeniably sweet oh when it has a heart
see that makes the industry feel okay
who do we root for don't forget to go
see good boys in theaters August 16th
I'm gonna be there the big vat of [ __ ]
popcorn cuz they'll be done shooting
this movie oh that's gonna be fun
I'm getting the popcorn and I'm getting
the chocolate-covered almonds and I'm
gonna sit there like the fat person I
truly have alright honey honey from the
makers of honey comes honey honey
honestly before I found out about honey
oh I love you seeing the promo code box
at the checkout stressed me out like
should I be typing something in there is
there a code I love that honey gave me
credit that I could actually get that
far when [ __ ] ordering something just
knowing that there could be a discount
out there made me
worried about overpaying every time I
shop online thankfully now I have honey
it's a free tool that connects to your
computer's browser as your as you're
shopping it scans the internet for
coupon codes and other discounts like
then like magic it automatically applies
the best one to your cart at checkout
honey will find oh honey
we'll find out running out ways to say
that we'll find you every coupon code
sale or discount on over 2,000 sites
like Amazon's odds-on j.crew eBay Macy's
Sephora what's that is that [ __ ] VIP
Macy's Nordstrom and MOA so you might
ask how do I get honey might help how do
I know honey has my back does it really
work was the lunar landing a hoax you
got all kinds of questions while honey
is there to [ __ ] answer them by the
way I believe we landed on the [ __ ]
moon just the amount of [ __ ] nerds
that you'd have to get them to keep
their mouths shut okay and you know
nerds they've never done anything cooler
in their life and if they fake the
[ __ ] lunar landing they'd be sit
there and the cat would be out of the
bag okay and as cruel as the CIA is I
think they draw the line at shooting
somebody who has tape between his
glasses back to the beat well not only
did honey test over 1 billion promo
codes last year but it actually applied
would utter at 85 million 67,000 86
working codes to people's orders that's
a lot of real life savings not to
mention over 10 million people are
already saving with her and it has over
100,000 five-star reviews on Google
Chrome store I don't know what any of
this is Google Chrome this is like a
[ __ ] airline every time you think
you're in Group one they create our new
group thanks to honey now there's
literally that way my Internet's [ __ ]
slow cuz every douche out there now has
Google Chrome
thanks to honey now there's literally no
stress when I see the promo code box at
checkout look there's no reason not to
use honey it's free
to use and easy to install on your
computer in just two clicks never
overthink that promo the promo code box
again get honey for free at join honey
dot-com / / that's join honey calm
/ / Oh online savings simplified alright
oh look who's back it's all zip hiring
used to be had just like an old man's
dick it used to be hard sorry multiple
job sites stacks of resumes a confusing
review process
but today hiring can be easy and you
have to go to you only have to go to one
place to get it done zip recruited calm
/ / zip sends your job to over 100 one
of the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip scans thousands
of resumes to find people with just the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip analyzes each one and spots
lights the top candidates so you never
miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employees who post on zip
look literally get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
and right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free that at this
exclusive website address zip recruiter
com
/ / that zip recruited Cobb / / zi p r e
CR UI ter comm / ber zip recruitable the
smartest way to hire all right there we
go is it time for the region is it time
for the reeds alright oh look at this
look at this one of the favorite rare
things that happens on this podcast but
it's starting to happen more because you
know what I asked the universe and when
you do that the universe provides
this is a question and it's coming from
away hey Bill I am a 19 year old lady
and I'm a huge fan I work with horses
and always listen to your podcast while
I'm riding and bringing horses in and
out is that dangerous
I mean I don't know you're on a [ __ ]
horse we're to get to worry about
another [ __ ] horse
I almost said texting while galloping
I'm sorry what is going on with me
what is it 19 [ __ ] 18 or in here
they'll get the comedy into 2019 it's a
gender-neutral horse I get so excited
for Mondays and Thursdays because it
makes work go by a little faster
when I get to listen to your podcast
well thank you I show everyone your
standup and you are by far my favorite
comedian what the [ __ ] okay you got a
question I'm German Irish I can't take
compliments I'm currently saving up
money to see you from my birthday
anyways thank you for brightening my day
with some laughter what the [ __ ] is that
email all about Jesus Christ you think I
got some heat coming my way see this
lady likes me
that was not me shaking my dick down at
the Port Authority as much as you might
think it was don't you get away with one
of those you get the are Kelly free pass
one time you can say that's not me and
then the second time they like now dude
that's you
all right 70s Atlanta Falcons fact all
right so a couple podcasts ago I was
talking about the very interesting
argument that somebody presented that
the 1977 Atlanta Falcons are actually
the best NFL defense of all time and
that includes the 1985 Super Bowl
shuffle monsters of the Midway Chicago
Bears and the [ __ ] 2000 Baltimore
Ravens who really should have had a
nickname for their defense you know you
think they would have but anyway and
they were saying because and they went
statistically but you know the game has
changed so much they only played they
played 14
games you know what I mean they played
in a [ __ ] week division I'm not
saying they weren't good buddy easy easy
to just sort of like well how many yards
do they give up passion yeah they gave
up a little bit let's just way too many
[ __ ] variables especially now with
the rules of coverage and all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can tell you this right
now the 77 Falcons the 85 Bears and the
2000 Baltimore Ravens would be giving up
way more [ __ ] yards than they did if
they had to play by today's you know
don't tackle them too hard rules so
anyway but I'm loving these old school
football facts so please keep them
coming in or any old-school sports
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] cricket I
don't give a [ __ ]
write something and I don't give a [ __ ]
alright 70s Atlanta Falcons fact a old
Billy reads a lot you and I are on the
same age and it appears we both got into
football around the same time growing up
in the Midwest I never watched the
Atlanta Falcons of the mid to late 70s
and never realized how dominant that
defense was until recently this is what
I was talking about your comments about
the Falcons on a recent podcast reminded
me of my favorite goof from that era and
I actually he sent this an accompanying
video hello so I will definitely put
tweet this out to this link this guy
Dave Hampton he said have you heard the
story about the first 100 1,000 yard
rusher Dave Hampton no it was the first
wasn't it the first it was Atlanta's
first thousand yard rusher I mean OJ was
[ __ ] tearing it up he was getting
2,000 yards up there in Buffalo you know
in case you haven't heard here are the
highlights with his shitty dude I just
almost made the most fucked-up joke
about OJ Simpson up there at Buffalo you
know when he was still dating black
chicks you know he was rushing for 2,000
yards
you know those chicks knew how to fight
so you know he [ __ ] focused on his
game then he got the 49ers you started
dating white chicks and it all went off
the [ __ ] rails are you blaming white
yes no okay in case you haven't heard
here are the highlights with the shitty
video clip at the end it's not shitty
it's great
Dave Hampton was playing in his last
game okay I'm gonna just I actually
watch the video so the Atlanta Falcons
were an expansion team I believe came in
the league in 66 what were they part of
the early 70s now I got to look that
fact up okay what am I gonna make you
guys do that at work people are gonna
know the enough did you listen to a
podcast not the [ __ ] stock report
whatever the hell he's supposed to be
doing I'll look it up Atlanta Falcons
wiki or football reference let's go with
those guys I like those guys better okay
Lana Falcons 1966 BAM there's yet
another fact that's never gonna make me
any money in life or get a roof over my
head but I know it 1966 they came in
early they were a [ __ ] joke okay
[ __ ] joke just got trampled they were
entire I don't know how many years of
existence and so they didn't have a lot
to cheer about so anyway they had this
guy Dave Hampton comes in the early 70s
all right it's a 14 game season so
getting a thousand yards was two games
harder it's still hard to this day
especially where they pass on all the
[ __ ] time it was really hard back
then especially the way they can [ __ ]
this [ __ ] they could do to you
he had like twist somebody's head all
the way back around before they call it
face up face off a facemask it seemed so
they're finally going to have their
first a thousand yard rusher 1,000 yard
rusher and the whole crowds going crazy
it's the only thing they have to cheer
about it's so to the point that in the
last game of the season
he keep rushes he gets he gets literally
like a thousand yards on the nose
there's a couple of minutes left they're
so [ __ ] excited they actually stopped
the game with two minutes left bring him
out to midfield they give him a [ __ ]
trophy and the game ball and the [ __ ]
game ball
and I didn't see that she holds the
trophy up and say you know what says
congratulations Dave Hampton first
thousand yards seized in 1970 whatever
the whole [ __ ] thing he's in his head
I'm taking the offensive line out for
steak dinners and all of this [ __ ] right
but now they've got two minutes left
so I'm thinking what's gonna happen he's
gonna go in the next play and they're
gays gonna blow out his [ __ ] knee and
he never plays again worse now not worse
but close they give him the ball in the
next play the quarterback stumbles he
pitches it the dude fumbles he didn't
really fumbles a bad pitch he cut went
off his hand he bounced he picks it up
like the athletic so-and-so that he is
and at this point it's a sweep the
[ __ ] team he's playing stretches it
out and they get him for a six yard loss
so now he's got 994 yards Oh guess what
happened the rest of the game people
this is a Charlie Brown story if I ever
[ __ ] heard one the poor [ __ ]
bastard
they don't that the other team is so
[ __ ] pissed that they had that whole
trophy ceremony they just stacked the
[ __ ] line and he doesn't get the
yards so now he's got this big [ __ ]
trophy for something he accomplished and
it was immediately taken away and NFL
Films makes this whole [ __ ] film
about just a step behind or some [ __ ]
about them and it gets worse the next
year same [ __ ] thing at this point
it's a thing all right
14th game of the season is he gonna
[ __ ] do it and the 49ers we're in
that division so you know they hated him
right they've just being [ __ ] and they
were like [ __ ] throw the ball all you
want this [ __ ] not getting a
thousand yards they stacked the [ __ ]
line at the end of the game again and he
doesn't get the thousand yards so then
the third season this is like a [ __ ]
movie there's finally a happy ending the
third season he's playing against the
Packers he needed like a sizable chunk
of yardage and he broke off like a 15
yard run and he went over the thousand
yard and the coach finally [ __ ] get
him out of the game got him out of the
game
and he finally [ __ ] he got finally
got his uh his thousand yards and you
see they actually interview the guy and
he's talking about it like people are
still talking about people aren't now I
just [ __ ] brought it up I hope I
didn't just start some [ __ ] again but I
would think if you played in the 70s and
eventually you got the thousand yards
you know and he did it with Atlanta so I
mean with the teams the Audion I'm ik
offense that they had back then I mean
that was like gaining like [ __ ] I
would say thirteen fourteen hundred
yards today I'm just gonna pull that
number right out of my freckled ass and
I'm gonna stand by it anyway this guy
says I hope you enjoy this and as always
gold blues and go [ __ ] yourself ah you
[ __ ]
congratulations on you Stanley Cup
championship I am happy for you as the
st. Louis Blues fan
alright god bless you it's the end of
July I'm letting it go alright Oh Mike
you know just came in uh oh I gotta hit
pause here hang on a second
all right I'm back I'm back had to say
hello to the kid oh and the lovely wife
and my kids awesome she loves that she
loves to roughhouse it's my favorite
thing ever
favorite thing ever anyway what am I
talking about here the 70s football blah
blah blah blah blah all the blues is
that what I ended on yeah I can [ __ ]
be man enough to say congrat
you're not supposed to be in here what
daddy's podcasting he says the bad words
bye-bye bye
watch yourself what's your figures
alright so anything scarier than
watching your toddler close the door you
like what your fingers yeah bill there's
other things that are scared well
whatever okay boyfriend is all talk oh
boy here we go here we go here we go oh
Jesus um hey Billy hey Billy for ladies
ladies I just realized my boyfriend is
all talk he talks about how funny is all
the time but the only people that laugh
at his jokes are his friends he said he
could have been on SNL if he had the
right surroundings as a child what the
[ __ ] does that even mean probably a
worst childhood than he had
I would think I think he's charming but
I have harder laughs with strangers when
I'm out doing errands oh my god please
don't ever tell him this when I tell him
he looks unhealthy he tells me it's cuz
he has a beard now and it's all in my
head he was in good shape when we met
but he's put on 20 pounds in the first
two years after college all right he
doesn't make you laugh you don't like
his beard you think he looks unhealthy
are you just gonna criticize your way
out of this [ __ ] relationship like
what's going on she goes it's not this
stupid looking beard she goes he put on
20 pounds of them the first two years
after college it's not the stupid beard
sorry
I actually [ __ ] up your perfectly
written joke there he says he's in great
shape but he's not he gets tired playing
with my nephew after like 10 minutes
dude you should be a [ __ ] comedian
you destroy in this guy and has never
made any effort to work out despite the
fact that he says he wants to and quote
will someday when his schedule allows it
I work a full-time job and still make
time to do Pilates four days a week
which requires me to wake up at 5:00
a.m. yeah you're basically an astronaut
and you're you're dating somebody who
watched the lunar landing that's
essentially what you're doing here okay
so anyways she goes I know I'm gonna
break up with them yeah I think all my
entire podcast fan base knows you're
gonna break up with them anyways I just
feel bad because he didn't do anything
wrong
it's just that we're way too different
and it's becoming more apparent as time
goes by it's as simple as that well you
know something congratulations to you
for realizing that she goes I want to be
honest with him and tell him he's full
of [ __ ] don't need to do that will that
help him in the future to have heard the
truth or will it make things worse not
just say the first half you don't have
to say I'm breaking up with you because
you're full of [ __ ] because he's gonna
be like oh my full is [ __ ] you're gonna
be like well first of all you say you're
funny and you're not okay your [ __ ]
friends laugh but that's just because
they got the patsy cline syndrome where
they call it Patty Hearst
right on what the [ __ ] it is you got him
held captive you say you're in shape
you're not you say you look sickly
because of your [ __ ] beard it isn't
it's cuz you gained 20 pounds you guess
what you're gonna do this guy you're
already gonna [ __ ] crush the guy if
he's in love with you I think he just
you said look you know you gonna break
up I just feel bad because he didn't do
anything wrong
just tell him look you didn't do
anything wrong I just need more and I
have to go figure out what that is
something's always the easy this escape
hatch you can [ __ ] pull but it's
that's such a huge [ __ ] thing to know
that you're not getting what you want
and to know and to be strong enough to
get out of it rather than settling with
some [ __ ] mushy bearded guy who
doesn't make you laugh congratulations
to you and don't be me okay just [ __ ]
lay it out there the first half you can
leave that other [ __ ] that's the other
[ __ ] you tell you [ __ ] girlfriends or
some [ __ ] alright alright there we go
plowing ahead here alright alright
girlfriend hates the gym well Jesus I
think I found you [ __ ] rebound guy
right here this guy's doing Pilates Oh
Billy Matchmaker over here hey Billy
Dingle dick I don't know what that means
I like it it sounds like what my dick is
like a round [ __ ] Christmas I do that
hang a little sleigh bells off it I'm
probably not that gets a little crowded
down there with all the balls if you
know what I mean I'm probably not the
first guy to ask you about this and I
probably won't be the last
I met the first guy I probably would be
less all right so me and my girlfriend
I've been dating for a year now and are
very much in love we've been living
together for a while now she eats good
food most of the time she's good most of
the time and is in decent shape but she
absolutely despises the gym and it's
only a matter of time before her Italian
family meals start to catch up with her
I mean look you get a lot of groans from
a live studio audience of [ __ ] cows
but you're being [ __ ] honest she's
told me to help her to lose weight lose
some weight but she makes it very
difficult when I tell her we can't get a
frosty from Wendy's at 10:00 p.m. she
acts all sweet and gives me the
puppy-dog face until I cave no brother
next time she does that you got to get
one of those Gatorades that you can
squeeze into somebody's mouth makes that
face
just [ __ ] squeeze it in there I need
to see a little more commitment don't do
that all right
telling her no is probably as hard as
telling your daughter she can't have any
more sweets that's wrong sir
that is wrong okay you don't love this
girl the way you're gonna love your kids
someday trust me all right and stop
copping out what it is you don't got the
[ __ ] cojones downstairs there to
[ __ ] say what you're feeling or maybe
you have the brains not to say it anyway
and convincing her to come to the gym
with me is no easy task either last week
I tried to get her to do an at-home abs
workout but she pulled down my pants and
decided to blow me instead so I'd leave
her alone Jesus Christ this woman hates
the chimp I mean she's just got one next
[ __ ] level you know what she's gonna
do when that one both those tricks don't
work she's gonna have to get creative
and start combining tricks honey I have
a fantasy I have a fantasy that I go to
Wendy's and I get a frosty and I blow
you I have that [ __ ] frosty in my
mouth
let me tell you she'll be swallowing
that night Oh shakes keep it clean keep
it above board Christ his kids walking
around anyway she says I'm definitely
going to let her do that for a while
longer but who knows how long that will
last
I still love her that's not a good line
I still love her I still love her sounds
like it's fading if you said look I love
this girl but but I still and I still
love her we're still hanging in there I
still love her oh I I'd still love her
if she gets fat but let's be honest who
wants
to be banging who doesn't want to be
banging a slim smoke show in the Middle
Ages exactly so bill what can I do then
there's nothing wrong with that if this
isn't what you're looking for this whole
[ __ ] thing that you have to accept a
fatty now and that there's some sort of
fun there borderline war heroes they
talk about fat people now like they were
in [ __ ] Fallujah it's ridiculous
anyway so bill what can I do to get her
to enjoy exercising without being a
complete dick to her thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself this is what you gotta do
before you tell it that you want to go
to the gym go jerk off so she won't
confuse you anymore all right what you
dealing with here this reminds me
because Mariano Rivera is going into the
Hall of Fame you know with Mario Rivera
what made him who's that
what are you doing is it bath time I'm
guessing his bath time high you can't
even see daddy all right you're gonna go
get a bath I'm gonna finish this up and
then I'm gonna put you to bed we're
gonna sing to you right before bed okay
did you just shrug your shoulders at me
bye bye buddy I love you love you too
bye [ __ ] hilarious every night before
the bath she just starts the second she
gets all her clothes off to eat she then
wants to run [ __ ] laps all around the
[ __ ] house
screaming now I'm naked but it's the
funniest [ __ ] thing ever
here she comes all right anyway listen
to your mother
that's called couch parenting while
passing it off on the other one learn
that skill said about six weeks ago and
I'm loving it
look it was bad what are you doing
all right close the door I gotta I gotta
finish this up anyway
what the hell was out Jesus Christ I was
talking about [ __ ] frosty [ __ ]
this has really gotten weird here
sorry I'm definitely gonna let okay what
do I do here um yeah this is like
Mariano Rivera where like everybody knew
what was coming and they couldn't hit it
the only in the same [ __ ] position
you like somebody facing Mariano Rivera
in the bottom of the night you know the
[ __ ] coming and it's just it's it's
gonna it's gonna take you down the
game's gonna be it's gonna be over
all right this is you want if you really
want to be a dick take the blow job okay
and then sing that and now we're going
to the gym see you back what are you
talking about Slyke well you just worked
all your neck muscles and I don't want
you back and you know all this other
stuff to be you know you don't be like
overdeveloped in your neck here I would
just sit down with her then just say
listen uh how you say how do you say I
don't have the [ __ ] energy to drag
you to the gym you're okay let's just
say what I want to say okay it's not my
[ __ ] job to drag your [ __ ] lard
ass to the nuts to me I'm not my job I
just have the [ __ ] energy to try to
get you go to the gym every [ __ ] day
all right yes the can't say it's too
[ __ ] mean just say listen I read
somewhere this is always great to cover
your inner thoughts I read somewhere
vague putting it off on this phantom
person with no footnote most people
won't call you out on I read somewhere
that oh Jesus I had it and I lost it I
read somewhere that you know the best
thing you can do for somebody is is let
them go to the gym on their own okay
it's just like a little kid at some
point you got to let them go and get out
there you know and take the training
wheels off or whatever and ride the
bicycle down the street please skip this
bicycle analogy it's [ __ ] terrible
you're immediately gonna be bombing you
start gonna get dry mouth and she's
gonna I don't know she's gonna start
crying just start with what the whatever
the [ __ ] I just said
okay so I'm gonna go to the gym I would
love for you to go to the gym with me
okay but I'm leaving it I'm gonna leave
it up to you okay who I will you don't
believe in me no no it's not that I just
feel like I'm pressuring you and it's
not something that you want to do right
now and it's just making me feel bad I
don't I don't want to be like
overbearing just gotta [ __ ] sit in
the pocket is she aims and Haws and Haws
and hems and then just say and just
stick to your [ __ ] guns like it isn't
up for debate all right
[ __ ] tattoo that on your forearm like
that guy in that [ __ ] movie when he
kept forgetting [ __ ] and just stick that
is the thing all right I'm going to the
gym all right
I would love to workout with you the
door is wide open I need you to walk
through it and then stand up and just
drop the frosty right on the [ __ ]
floor and you're out
please videotape that let me know how it
comes all right lining it up weighing it
down here right here wrapping it up
winding it down wrapping it up winding
it up that's how my brain works sorry
overrated underrated I used to have
these all the time stuff that's
overrated stuff that's underrated right
underrated haven't you [ __ ] metro
card out you know ready to [ __ ] go
through the turnstile all right
overrated taking a [ __ ] Express train
when you live in Manhattan
it never really passes the local it's a
[ __ ] pipe dream you need to go to
least three Express stops for it to be
worth you well and I'm not counting 34th
and 42nd cuz that's the one that slows
you down that's a little clogged in the
artery there alright dear Big Daddy
Billy Bob I've got an interesting
overrated verse underrated topic for you
I think going on vacation is overrated
think about it how much time preparation
and stress does it take to go on
vacation I'm with you you end up more
stressed than you would have been
staying at home and spending time with
your family oh my god
genius man a woman who wrote that it's
[ __ ] genius
I'll tell you know it's a great vacation
a vacation that you can drive too
quickly alright I'll tell you what we
should have done my family says done
license [ __ ] take advantage all the
[ __ ] lakes when I was living out here
on the East Coast go up to New Hampshire
you know just [ __ ] go to a [ __ ]
Lake [ __ ] the airport [ __ ] those [ __ ]
airlines with yeah you can only use your
miles when we say you get out really
[ __ ] your miles I'm going to a lake just
sit on a [ __ ] Lake just don't have it
be a long drive and this is another
thing getting home earlier you know and
just [ __ ] being at home for a couple
of days and you don't tell anybody that
you're home shut your [ __ ] phone off
tell everybody you're going to Greece
and stay home how is Greece it was great
then they find out later you know you
never wait your grace you know I had
[ __ ] greasy breakfast every day does
everybody know Jesus all right which
leads me to my next point
having no plans for the weekend is
underrated absolutely it is when you
have nothing to do that equals free time
free time to do whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do what do you think bill I
think there was two nails and you
[ __ ] hit they [ __ ] ahead of each
one of them I don't think a nail gun
could have [ __ ] done better than what
the [ __ ] you just did with that hammer
and those two nails yeah that that is
100% [ __ ] true you know unless you
have like a dream vacation I've always
wanted to go to Rhode Island you know
then I say go I said an island was
surrounded on all sides by water
go have a good time right go to Greece I
mean I would do that you know but other
than that dude like I'm telling you JFK
Newark LaGuardia LAX O'Hare I'm trying
to find one that isn't [ __ ] stressful
unless you can somehow fly a short
Southwest flight out of like Dallas Love
Field you know or maybe like Long Beach
fly out a [ __ ] Long Beach or
something like that just something that
just makes the airport a little bit
easier I don't know what but I am big on
the I'll tell you right now everybody
makes fun of a [ __ ] RV I want to hear
from RV people oh I'm getting the itch
man I'm getting a fever getting that RV
fever I get it every [ __ ] summer I
told you I want to get a [ __ ] GMC
[ __ ] RV from the 70s the green one I
want to get one of those [ __ ] things
so bad you know I just have no place to
put it and that's one of those one of
those things my wife was looking at me
and I just I'm like you're right I know
I know but come on
let's do it you know it's funny I should
just [ __ ] do it I should decide the
guy who built my truck I should just
have him buy one of those [ __ ] things
and just make one of those [ __ ]
things and I should tell her I should
[ __ ] tell her that we're going on a
local vacation which is not going to
excite her alright and then I just pull
up what I think you're [ __ ] chariots
sweetheart and she's gonna get on there
big smile on her face I'll have a little
bit of rose' I'll be sitting up front
like an old man you know old man they
always way that sailor [ __ ] hat the
captain of the ship right just [ __ ]
drive another [ __ ] oh my god
get the [ __ ] TV going for my kid baby
shark dodo dodo dodo get that [ __ ]
thing going
I haven't build in a little [ __ ]
humidor in there I mean Jesus Christ I
think I just talked myself back into it
now alright dilemma Bill I oh my god I
have to have neon to tell you the story
of this woman who [ __ ] punched her in
the neck and [ __ ] Times Square she
has to come I'm teasing yeah I'm teasing
you for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast I'm
gonna have as my special guest my
special lady
and she's gonna tell the story and I was
there when it happened
and I had to get in between them two
females um
dilemma bill I have a tough / stupid one
for you for the rest of your life you
can never use furniture I miss all of
this overrated underrated and dilemma I
miss these for the rest of your life you
can never use furniture no bed no couch
no chairs or behind door number two for
the rest of your life you can never
leave the city you reside in which do
you choose
dude I'm a traveling comedian that's how
I make my money so the only way I win is
if I pick Las Vegas and they become a
casino comic sitting in that heat with
global warming just getting worse every
[ __ ] year no bed no couch no chairs
for the rest of your life you can never
use furniture you know what [ __ ] that
I'm picking I'm gonna stay in the same
city and I'll make it [ __ ] work
because I'll tell you right now like
your health is more important than
[ __ ] traveling and if I'm gonna be
laying on the floor like a goddamn king
can I have a [ __ ] yoga mat well
that's not furniture right wait a minute
wait let's see if Billy can build a nest
here you didn't say anything about an
air mattress oh my god how sad would
that be every night with that little
[ __ ] motor filling up the [ __ ]
mattress people in the next [ __ ]
motel thinking you got gas it's like the
longest one I ever heard
yeah I'm gonna have to say I would I
would can I choose
I'd have to say no furniture I would go
with like a [ __ ] air mattress look us
homeless people I mean they've well
Jesus Christ look how they look bill I
mean they sleep on the [ __ ] Street
cardboard box fold it up and I'd be a
lot of cardboard boxes
God knows those things attract [ __ ]
rats I would still have to I would pick
travel but then that means like Dwight
does my whole family they can't have
furniture because my kids not growing up
not knowing where abetters if you say my
whole family then I would choose staying
in the city but it was if it was just me
if I was like Bill Bixby just had a
backpack traveling around you know can
other people can I like hook up with
chicks on the road you know use their
furniture I don't know that's a tough
one man that's a tough one but with if
I'm if I'm choosing my family like Liam
Neeson then I would go with the
furniture if I'm by myself I would
choose to travel Oh Billy Appleseed here
all right that's the podcast okay go
[ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on you with a juicy
story for my lovely wife about getting
punched in the [ __ ] neck in Times
Square all right I'll see you